good morning everyone welcome back to
gamespot live i'm richie and today we
are going to be playing some call of
duty
early access beta this is a beta for
playstation uh players who have
pre-ordered the game
so
that'll do it for me let's jump right
into it i'm going to switch over to the
screen here how is everyone doing
there we go okay
there it is
um let's see here we got a chance to
play game spot got a chance to play this
a little early and i'm really excited
because the beta adds
a lot of uh way more stuff than just
champion hill and this is uh for those
of you asking in the chat this is
playstation 5 gameplay
you should be able to download this on
your playstation 4 as well if you
pre-ordered the game but i've heard
that's giving people problems this
morning
um but i can't i can't i'm not sure if i
can help because uh i'm currently
playing on uh the ps5
but here we go we'll jump into a quick
quick play uh matchmaking here they've
got
way more modes than before and they have
combat pacing which i think i actually
have to unlock so
wish me luck let's get into it let's see
if i can get into a match it's a
that's that's a common issue
no loadouts yet i think i have to be
level like 10 or something
oh level 4. that's not bad at all
cool cool
uh
richie in the chat hey another from one
richie to another uh he asks how's the
game and
i like it um
i'm really digging it we got to play the
beta like a few weeks ago this is my
first match with like the public beta
and i'm really digging it there's a lot
to like here
make sure my movement's all good and i'm
going to move my mic forward here let me
see
there we go kill confirmed okay
and this is this is tactical game play
so uh uh i'm sorry it's a tactical game
mode so it'll be 6v6
there are other mo [ __ ] there are um
other combat pacing modes like
tactical's the slow one 6v6
there's uh blitz which is like god i
think it's 24v24 and then somewhere in
the middle which is called assault
something was wrong here hold on um
when i got killed by that guy something
i'll figure it out you know all the
settings i have to we still have to
figure out
there we go the stg 44 seems to be the
fan favorite so far hey oh it's my
triggers i don't like
i don't like what my triggers are doing
i think they have those uh settings on
where the triggers let's see here
there we go yeah there's like some
resistance so i want to turn that off
hey relax y'all shooting each other
hmm
this map uh hotel royal is very nice
it's cool it's like indoor outdoor on
the top of a
a fancy hotel
a little little laggy here just a little
someone died down there i'm not picking
that up
whoa
oh at least i got that tag
is it fun so far i'm having fun um it's
kind of a
it's
in the way like general gameplay feels
it reminds me of modern warfare 2019
which i loved because you know little
things like um you can mount
and you can uh double you can tax print
like
you know double sprint
i knew he was there got him yes
uh and the gunsmith is like identical
it's like the same thing
so you can you can highly customize your
gun in this game which is cool because
you know world war ii guns aren't the
most customizable in real life but
whoa
oh [ __ ] sorry um but they made they
changed that in this game you can have
like 10 attachments on this gun
got him
through the wall
oh no
i got greedy
vlad in the chat says same old same old
i mean yeah it's easy to be it's really
easy to be uh you know to feel that way
about call of duty uh in a lot of ways
it is the same old but
uh it's just enough for me i'm i'm
definitely enjoying myself so far
it's very early but um i'm definitely
digging it and i hope you guys get a
chance to play for yourself soon oh sh
cat zooks
my world is spinning that's funny
yes
hey that guy stole my tags
oh no all right
uh
yolt's in the chat if you didn't pre or
if you did not pre-order the game i
don't think you'll be able to play until
we see i have the dates here
until the 16th
yeah that's when it goes open for
playstation users it's a it becomes an
open beta at that point
okay okay
let me know guys i'm keeping a chat or
i'm keeping an eye on chat of course but
i want to um make sure the sounds okay
every time i i stream i notice that i my
head faces a different direction and
my voice just gets kind of low so let me
know if that's a problem
heard someone right here
oh my god the muzzle flares
this is pretty nuts
that guy was just hanging out up here
hey logan welcome
happy friday
okay i just got lucky there i should
have died like twice oh crap john wick's
dog
can't kill him
how's the game good or bad um short
answer for me good i like it
it's uh it's very early but this beta is
much is much cooler than the alpha
because you know i don't like uh
champion hill mode that as much as i do
regular multiplayer so
short answer good i and i'm having fun
what's going on here that guy is just
hanging out
got him how are we doing okay good we're
winning oh my good
goodness gracious
well i have a glide bomb but this is
kind of a half half map
yeah i don't know if it'll work that
well well there's someone outside no
they went in yeah
there we go what else do i have a
a death okay cool cool cool
can i blow up walls and buildings kind
of
um
there there's like semi uh there's like
some minor destruction you can do but
most of it's already broken like i think
you can break doors entirely
i'll show you this
close
oh my settings are off again hey man
all right so you can like shoot through
this and break stuff like that like an
apex
um and then there are a lot of walls
that break
um in the same way
sorry my actions are getting me killed
here
um
yeah it's not it's nothing crazy but
sometimes it helps like in a pinch
hey this guy's over here
getting used to these maps
that's it for the intel
oh my uav is gone
oh yeah go this way
oh no
hey there we go oh see that little
secret pathway is is helpful
we're rolling deep here this is like
four people or three
okay
this tactical gameplay which is 6v6 only
is
i mean obviously pretty slow pace but
the last time i played this map we had
blitz mode which was 24v24 and it was
non-stop it was nuts so it's actually
kind of refreshing to just chill and
play 6v6 i think yeah 6v6 max
i shuffled the game modes around so we
might get a match of uh
blitz mode which is 24v24 let me see
here this map looks like a cluster doors
don't break if you don't shoot them in a
pack oh maybe i'm thinking if you like
throw a grenade right can't you bomb
them and then um
they
they're not there anymore i haven't
played apex in such a long time i love
that game
yeah you can kind of break them here and
then i'm sure if you throw a grenade
they'll blow up all the way
i'll try a different gun next uh
next death
this here in the center is obviously
where all the action is normally but
6v6 mode a little slower a little chill
hey
where's everyone
maybe it's a little too slow
oh no
oh he was to my left okay
james in the chat says best game ever
man
my beta won't start at all um
ronaldo if you didn't pre-order the game
even if you're on playstation you won't
be able to play just yet
unfortunately
oh there were two people there that's a
little hard to see
it is that is correct it is the same
engine as modern warfare it's a little
more updated they said
um so that that you know
if you are not a fan of that
it's like war zone you know which is
also the same engine
how'd i do
mid below mid
how the graphics on ps5 that's up to you
to decide man i think they're okay i
don't think it's that big of a jump in
in graphics if i'm being honest
and i am playing it on ps5 right now uh
looks good the whole game is kind of
like it's got that muddy look so
that definitely
affects it
worst game there we go that's it
worst game ever says fraga
is it a pc game uh it will be right now
i think the pc dates are
yeah the pc dates are
later in the month on the 18th i think
battlefield looks better
i am excited for battlefield
so i'm not going to dump on your parade
there but um
i'm excited for both
because this will be my first
battlefield this year i never haven't
played it
so i'm excited for that i'm excited for
halo and i'm still
still excited for this year's call of
duty of course but um
what else uh i'm still playing split
gate every now and then so i'm still
digging that but
i don't know i don't play like
let's see
in fact i was actually actually playing
sonic colors i love
that that's back
but i play games uh
like i don't play i don't scatter my
gameplay time across a lot of games when
i play games i'm usually playing like
one or two games until i'm absolutely
sick of it that's just how i
generally play
and uh call of duty loves that oh these
guys are upstairs
i'm gonna sneak around
footsteps are quieter in this game where
the hell are the stairs ah
watch i can like break through this like
kool-aid kool-aid man
we are the
this is another 6v6 match
i didn't check because that's
the tactical mode it's a little little
slower paced
oh someone's over here
saw them on the on the uav
i haven't tried the volk this will be
cool
the volksware
remember that big old name from uh
world war
call of duty world war ii
oh that guy was
that person was just looking down i
don't know what's going on
oh man
oh well
this map is cool so far it's called red
star
yeah the space that's a big
subject of controversy uh the space says
why are there optics like that on these
world war ii guns
that you can you can also have up to 10
attachments so like you know reality
takes a big back seat here
great that's a miss
hmm here we go here's some little
destructible wall
but yeah it's not much they're really
marketing it and it's kind of cool and
helpful sometimes but uh overall like
take it or leave it for me
hey
oh my god
turn the sdg into an mp5 dude that's
the sdg is like the fan favorite gun
from what i've seen so far
uh so i'm sure people will have mp5
builds in no time
oh it's so snowy oh crap
yeah
yeah historical accuracy yeah maybe
don't worry about it in this game
what the oh he's on the roof
yeah the the their historical fiction is
probably like the best way to put it
they said they're like
uh
beholden to history but not tied to it
so that's their way of saying like hey
man we're gonna have some fun
oh crap
hmm
i guess he didn't come through oh wait
you can go around here
he was still there somewhere
yeah he's he's not moving crap oh it's a
friendly
do you guys turn your color blind
settings on i heard um even if you're
not colorblind and you tweak some
settings it's easier to see like names
over people's heads
brandon hernandez what's up man happy
friday
oh man stefano the chat says halo
infinite is going to be my first halo
since reach it'll be mine since three
dude i'm pretty excited
did you get to play split gate who was
that in the chat um
stefan
split kate was really fun really
reminded me of halo 2 and i know
everyone says that but it's because it's
really true
oh man there was a third i could have
had a triple
hey ali ali in the chat uh modern
warfare or vanguard um
i i will always
hold modern warfare 2019 very high so
right now it's still my favorite but
there's a lot of similarities like
this is like the modern warfare 2019 of
world war ii
uh for
for a lot of uh
familiar reasons like you know
ah crap
like tax print and stuff like that and
um gun customization even the ui is
similar in some ways
is raven and treyarch doing the zombies
treyarch is doing the zombies which is
great
like
they created the zombies mode they have
the best stories and stuff so they'll be
handling it this year even though
sledgehammer games is making everything
else
um
treyarch will be handling the zombies
mode they haven't talked about that much
at all this year though
uh but i can't wait to see that because
i love zombies
especially when treyarch does it
is this just a copy of modern warfare
see i'm telling you it feels that way
huh or at least looks and sounds that
way
but to me like
that's not everyone's cup of tea but for
me i'm i'm thrilled because i love
modern warfare 2019
dude i'm just going around the perimeter
too much i need to find people
where the people at
oh crap there's one
ooh
digital bar bear digital bear oh crap
dang it
cool yvonne yvonne we got
he says uh this actually looks good all
right i mean
that's cool that's great
um
i know a lot of people are here
generally
genuinely curious to just see if they're
gonna give this another call uh this
call of duty another try this year
a lot of people are like nope same old
so it's nice to hear someone pretty
interested in this because i am i
i i really like what i'm playing so far
and this beta is so much better than the
alpha the alpha just had that one game
mode you know champion hill
um
oh crap
yoink
come on mp40
goodness gracious
going around
oh no
lay off
that was like the worst gunfight ever
but i deserved to lose that one
they're putting me on oh crap
okay now for some reason there's a ton
of people
piling up on me
i picked up the wrong gun
would i rate this out of 10 right now
it's too early to tell i'm having a lot
of fun with it but
things always change this beta is um
much better than the alpha though i'll
say that
i hope you get a chance to play right
now this is an early access beta for
playstation users
but only ones who
uh pre-ordered the game
come on
okay
again i think i should have died there
but uh the game has spoken
oh there's like 9 000 people over there
9 000 people
eagle says game looks fun it is fun i
mean opinion you know opinion here
i think it is fun oh i have a glide bomb
excuse me one second
yeah
what okay i got one
i guess glide bombs don't have that much
uh splash damage
i also want to check out my other
killstreaks and see what
see what's available
there was like i remember there was some
like like dogs and uh
none of them were like
too flashy but i definitely want to
change mine around for the next match
someone's on the roof
someone was on the roof
our second story
show yourself
i think that landed on the ground next
to me dang it what
i thought those were footsteps it's like
the the countdown clock
dang it
what will this cost i'm sure whatever
like you know
i don't know 59.99 i don't know i'm not
i'm not not selling this game i'm not
sure what the price whatever a regular
new game costs on ps5
uh next match i'll use a different gun
oh someone's over here
ah oh and he killed me look at that
disrespectful
dogs no benjamin no i hate the dogs i
mean
i don't like
shooting all the dogs and games i think
that should stop
what's the difference from cod world war
two they i mean
there's more of a modern warfare
vibe for this game and you can customize
your guns way more here in this game
which is pretty cool
let me back out here and um
see what's up with the ui see what i
unlocked
excuse me
here we go
yeah look at the regular stuff spy plane
oh
intel is different than a uav i forgot
the uav shows i think your whole team
yeah yeah
death machine of course
mortars
war machine which was okay
in my opinion
i haven't tried the flame not yet
in the in the in our beta test the flame
not kept crashing the game so i'm sure
they fixed it by now but
um
i haven't tried it myself
let's see here well i don't have
anything else unlocked i think the max
you can go up to is level 20 and i'm
only on top right there you can see
level three
so i'll come back to that later
and let's see here
no chimp tactical tactical is 6v6 so i'm
gonna just do the regular
playlist here and see what's up
jonathan kelly this needs to be at 39.99
that'd be cool
what are the snipers like um
i've only tried out one of them and it
was good it was a regular um
one shot kill from the chest up i forget
what it was there the car 98 is also
here but i used another one i forgot
what it was
and then langer in the chat
how many vans do we guard dude the whole
game that's all you're doing so just
infant infinite
what kind of vans like scooby doo yeah
there's all sorts of vans
uh mostly vans from the 1940s as you
would imagine but you gotta guard all of
them it's your only job in this game to
guard the vans
abdullah says hey
don't you think cod gets more slow over
the years
and when people try to slow it down i
think it gets fast again like no matter
what you do remember the
in war zone the time to kill was pretty
slow when it started
people make all these fast builds
and um
it gets fast again no matter what you do
i think especially uh i think cold war
was pretty fast
unless you have armor on um
no matter what you do it'll be pretty
fast people will make it fast i think
that one
i heard a bullet ricochet like past my
ear that was pretty cool
uh yeah sorry i just went with this
random pre-built class with the mg i
like mg so i'm excited to use this but
this thing is honking i'm running around
pretty slow
got one right here come on
oh my goodness
oh no he has a grenade
he did
oh i got two i got too picky with the
tags
character customization i don't think so
there it's like before where there are
operators and
um
you can buy
or whatever earn or download skins for
them but
no character customization
there we go
going around bringing around town
hey i got a glide bomb
cool beans i'm gonna go use it over here
in privacy
am i playing at 120 no this monitor that
i have is not
oh that was the roof it's not compatible
of that so
no
um
should be an option but
you know if you have the right monitor
but i don't know if um
that's just for multiplayer maybe just
single player mode
good question i don't
wow loading into a match fast yeah
matchmaking is okay uh during the our
little closed beta it was pretty rough
but that oh there was a guy over there
but that makes sense you know they were
they were keeping privacy
um
when we played this as a private beta
they kept the privacy walls like up so
you had to like
sign into everything to even play this
game
to avoid people like just jumping into
the beta
but now matchmaking seems to be okay
there's a lot going on over here
damn it
peek my head out like a dork
not famous says i need to see the
campaign multiplayer is good but the
trailer of the campaign is fire oh yeah
i can't wait for the campaign either but
no sign of uh you know that sort of demo
every time they do a demo or a play test
now
it's always um multiplayer i'm gonna
switch guns
i need i need a faster ads here keep
losing to that same guy
the tommy gun's pretty good it kicks
oh this guy got you oh i got you i don't
care if i die here
who's that tallam gaming killed me okay
fine
stop watching kill cams they're a great
way for me
to chat with you guys
hey peek your head out again homeboy
hey you stole my tags
partial credit
cool did you see that level four i
unlocked a custom class so
next match i will build
i will build my own gun
there we go a little packet burst there
that's what it says
ooh
bring home the money i don't know if
you're looking for some high kill
gameplay
uh
i'm a
i mean
never mind i'm not gonna uh degrade
myself that much here but i like call of
duty a lot but i've never i've never
been the best it's funny i always say
for as long as i've played call of duty
my skill gap
has only slightly increased so like i'm
not
a bot despite
some gameplay here but
i'm also not the best there's so god so
many people are just good at call of
duty and i'll never be that good but
like i'm okay with that oh someone died
over here
oh god
no
rock i got killed by roxas wow
organization 13 in the house
uh but let me know what you guys are
thinking so far i mean um
like how did the maps look to you how
does the gun sound to you are you
i assume you're here because you're
interested to
maybe play um when the beta goes live
for you guys
let me know
thompson isn't working for me as well as
i thought let's see here mayhem ooh the
bar okay i'll try the bar no i don't
like the scope on the bar though
well it's not that bad
okay the bar is cursed
next next gun
mp40 has been good to me too
did i try the volk yet i'll do that
zombies i wish there were uh zombies in
this there will be later this year but
there's no it's not in the beta
i did try the volk this gun is good
it's speedy
uh there is no sorry i think i missed
that question there is no fov slider
there will be one but in the beta there
currently isn't
but one of the people from sledgehammer
came out and uh you know you might have
seen it on twitter they
posted a screenshot of the fov slider on
console so it's coming
rats peeking my head out
yeah uh andrew salazar i got a thing
from
call of duty here that gives me the
dates for all the betas
this is the closed beta for
playstation people who have
pre-ordered the game
but uh give me a second here guys i'm
just gonna read this off uh the xbox
early access uh beta will be on
september 16th or the 17th
the playstation open beta for everyone
on playstation will be
from the 16th through the 20th
and then there'll be another
open beta for everyone from the 18th
through the 20th we won all right cool
what about hackers i haven't i mean
fortunately this is uh i haven't run
into any i know there are console
hackers but this is only on ps5 right
now and i'm not i haven't noticed any
egregious hackers maybe except for that
guy with the kill cam but
will it be on ps4 or fov on ps4 i think
that's the plan yeah i think so
the music just went up in my ears did it
go up for you guys
here we go let me back out and make a
custom class i can do that now
okay
um i did like the volk this gun here
where is it
oh never mind it's not not a pre-built
wait yeah it was where is it
whatever i'm going to make my own class
here
oh the volk was
an ar
duh but it's not it's not locked all
right it is locked damn it
oh well let's see what else we got what
can i
make a thompson class the shotgun which
no thanks
m1 garand i can't do the m i can't do
the m1 garand ping yet because i don't
have it although i think it's in it's in
a pre-built class
yeah i can't
no m1 yet well
it's like hey they they opened up the
customization and then they were like oh
you can't do anything with it right now
what are you doing in the game
um i'll make an stg build i like this
gun
it's like a good all-around ar maybe a
little
maybe a little cracked
i don't yeah i don't even have anything
for this what am i doing oh but real
quick before i jump into another game
look at um there's as many attachments
unreal ass attachments here as there are
in
modern warfare 2019 look at the scopes i
love this
look at all the you can change your iron
sights
um there are multiple iron sights there
are so many
goofy ass fake scopes
kiss reality
goodbye
look at this
look at this
what is that no it's an ir
it's an ir scope
oh
that one looks somewhat real some of
them i'm sure
might be based off of history but no i
don't know like no half of these no
i don't know though i'm not a no we
gotta
oh my god someone in the comments was
like
jonathan ferguson needs to react to all
of these and i was like yes that needs
to happen now
okay no more uh no more that let's jump
into a
a match here
bryce i'm sorry i can't m1 right now
it's locked
so if they are going to do it on ps4 and
warzone why don't they do it on modern
warfare multiplayer
what do you mean oh the fov slider
i'm not sure man not in charge of making
those decisions my friend
whoa
puko pico says van vanguard will beat
battlefield i don't know man
i don't know it will definitely have its
audience but battlefield is
battlefield is ready this year
battlefield is going to be lit
fishing world says i can't get in uh did
you pre-order the game on playstation
that's the only way to get in this
weekend
next weekend
it'll be open for all playstation users
okay we get to try out the new mode
on a new map uh patrol is hardpoint
but the hardpoint moves like a snail
across the map
so wish me luck gang
hmm
no you guys don't want to see me snipe i
am when it comes to sniping i'm
bad
so let's see here
was there an m1 if there is a pre-built
m1 class i will use it for you guys
but there isn't
wait default here we go here we go
look at that you guys
this is for chat i'm going to waste this
and then
did you hear that
[Music]
this map is a little tough because it's
easy to get pinned down in your spawn
but the play test group that i played
with seem to have like seemed to like it
all right play the objective richie
let's go let's capture the moving
hardpoint
no no no
have i have i ever beat a cheater in war
zone no way dude
not even on accident and i love when
that happens though
oh my god just rod times two
wasted me
see
oh my god this thing is so jumpy
but look at that i'll take that double
all day
why did i throw a smoke this is a patrol
zone that moves
oh i saw all the do you see those sniper
glints look dude wanted to use the
oh no he's using the three-line rifle
which uh i forget what actually is what
it's called
no no
oh that's a shotgun i'm toast
why am i not toast i should have lost
that
i should have lost that gunfight like
twice
look they came back for me the the
lonely homie 27 came back for me
all right um
the m1 i don't know guys i think
[ __ ] i'm dead
i'm toast
wow that grenade took forever
did they
i'm dazed
what is this oh shoot
no time to no time to figure that out
call of duty and battlefield graphics
comparison we thought of that actually
uh but it's you know
different um
a lot of differences there i just killed
myself let me get a different gun and
just start that over
all right
we are losing but we have the patrol
zone right now at least
okay
dang it
i want to play blitz mode blitz mode is
the 24v24
thoughts on time to kill um
i'm always a pretty bad person to ask
when it comes to that i feel like it's
like oh shoot
like look at that that was like still
well less than a second but like
i would say it's pretty fast because
there are so many attachments that beef
up your gun in this game you can have 10
attachments on on like any gun
uh so that time to kill is going to get
pretty fast
look at this destructible cover
look at that peekaboo
that's what i get i'll just try to show
off the destructible cover but those are
the consequences i'm gonna go back to
playing the objective
someone's over there
oh it's the lonely homie27
we go at least that guy was trying now
i'm here with my
whoo
come on we gotta get this back up damn
it i didn't look up
andrew ochoa in the chat says this looks
pretty cool
xbox gamer says the multiplayer of halo
can be fun absolutely
it's uh the highlight of that series is
the multiplayer
going around bringing around town
if i can oh crap that dude was he was on
patrol for sure
he was doing his job
we are getting spanked
oh man i thought i had that triple
i'm not even going for kills i just want
to get to the patrol zone and get our
points back
smoke out okay that guy was camping in
the bushes
you know xbox
oh
friendly
oh come on oh that other guy shot me i
was like okay i had shots on that guy
for show
turns out i'm not a good patrol player
or
my team we can use some help
ah
joshua gonzalez says
this is a copy and paste of modern war
of modern warfare not worth 70 bucks
that is your evaluation and you have a
voice here that's cool
um but i loved modern warfare so i would
i would i would pay
because i love modern warfare because
you're right it it looks and feels a lot
like uh move homie
god uh it looks a lot like modern
warfare 2019
same engine
oh
xbox gamer says i play too much modern
warfare and a little less cold war
that's kind of where i'm at too i played
a lot of cold war at the beginning and
then i kept around i stuck around for
zombies that's a friendly um but then
i didn't stick around as long as i did
for
[ __ ]
i was reloading i didn't stick around
for cold war as long as i did for modern
warfare
oh my goodness we're getting bombed
what
okay i don't know let me watch this one
oh he was blind firing
that's a friendly dude go the other way
get to the patrol zone patrol zone
come on
there you go solid snake in the chat
that's cool you have your opinion too
he's like uh he's gonna pick up this
game
and yeah one person doesn't speak for
the whole chat that's for sure
but uh
i'm glad you guys are all here either
way you know making making your decision
um or at least checking out you know
because you're interested
to see what's up with the new call of
duty this year
ah crap and this weekend especially
because you have to play the beta this
weekend you had to have pre-ordered the
game which is like
not cool but next weekend um it'll be
open for all playstation users whether
or not you pre-ordered
september 16th through the 20th
this guy is hungry
oh my god i don't like patrol but um
i mean look the results speak for
themselves
uh is it free to play on september 16th
for pc
the pc dates
if you pre-ordered it
um on if you pre-ordered it on pc
you will have the early access beta
september 16th through the 17th
but then the open beta for everyone
cross console is from the 18th through
the 20th
hold on let me see if here if i can
change my uh
there's only tactical pacing which is um
6v6 and i want to try to get some more
crazy gameplay with like 24v24 but
right now i don't think it's an option i
don't think i can unlock it
yeah see the filter lock on the right i
can't i can't pick my game mode
or the combat pacing so
i'll stick with uh i guess this playlist
here
if it's ender in the chat i see you
ex burke what's going on thanks for
joining um so far i personally like the
game there are mixed opinions and as
always as you will see in the chat
uh some people are saying it's kind of
just like a reskin of modern warfare
which is fine by me because i personally
love that game but
you know your results may vary i can't
wait to see the new warzone
vanguard map that i'm excited for
can can yeah affordability i feel like
games are slowly going up finally
and
this uh
this beta will be cool for people who
want to try it out and make a really
strong informed decision but even then
it's a hard ask every year to like you
know
pay up
for for
what might feel like a call of duty copy
and paste experience so
it's all so subjective people have their
reasons for everything and that's
one of them
what are we doing
going for b
bam oh
we had the same thoughts there
should i go for c no i'm not gonna
triple cap these guys oh they're taking
baker okay maybe i'll sneak in for c
i could defend b but i'm closer to c so
i'm going for it
and they're taking able
come on help me out i'm alone
fine i don't need your help
solo cap
okay they took b let me see i see one
guy be a friendly at b
wow i jumped out the window and broke my
legs what's new
oh no i didn't even check my sides
yeah
yeah if you want that's true solid snake
uh a good graphics card for this game to
run well is not cheap either
this dude's name is sauce look at that
quit taking able
enough
oh i need smoke grenades on this class
which is a hot edit i can do right now
look at that
stun
69 stun smoke i'll take it
cool we got hey
oh
see that someone's looking at me not
gonna i'm not gonna poke my head out
that way
maybe i'll go for b a lot of them were
at c just now i saw that so wish me luck
go this way actually jumping through a
window or something
yoink
grenade
oh that was fast see that was a fast
time to kill
is the beta already out for this game
this is a uh a beta for playstation
users if you pre-order so it's kind of a
limited
closed beta but it's out if you
pre-order the game next weekend it'll be
open to all playstation
all playstation players even if you
didn't pre-order
oh no hey what the heck i tried to i
tried to uh go prone all the way my
button didn't let me
try that hello from earth
my favorite planet that's for sure
[Laughter]
that's where i'm from i'll say that
all right i'm going for their c they
keep taking able enough
enough
securing charlie all right level it up
that's it for the intel oh we are neck
and neck here it's like
69 to 64.
maybe if they didn't keep taking a ball
pathetic
f
whoa broke my legs
whoa
okay going prone takes forever it takes
five ever
man he was okay that was a little hard
to see plus he was camping
capturing
is the graphics the graphics better than
modern modern warfare 2019 a little bit
it's polished uh because it's the same
engine but it's like you know a slightly
better version of that engine they say
and uh
looks good to me plays good to me but
yeah it plays similar similarly to
modern warfare 2019 and of course
warzone gonna go back to
i was surrounded
the revolving shotgun no way
i hated that gun i got no kills with
using that gun do weapons feel good yeah
um you can add up to 10 attachments on
these things so it feels like
it feels like you're playing a world war
ii game with like newer guns because you
can really beef them up so
i'm enjoying myself when it comes to
that for sure
you have 10 attachments that's that's
insane but like insanely cool there's
about to be some
cracked guns
for this uh for this game coming up
oh yeah
oh i didn't mean a triple cap wait i
thought we didn't have a oh well
whatever let's get these points back
okay and they took baker anyway
you never see through this little window
oh there's i saw some guy's foot like
i think i'm being watched is that what
he said
we don't need baker man
whatever
let's just trip cap and get this over
all right going for backup for baker
let's go b
oh see he shot me through a little piece
of destructible cover i think watch
let's let's watch
yeah
that door
is it free yet for pc no pc open beta
build is i think
i have it on my piece of paper it is
from the 18th through the 20th if you
pre-ordered the game you can play that
beta
from the 16th through the 20th i think
but you know how call of duty does you
got to pre-order to get like super early
access
enough
i think i want to try another smg
okay i just saw smoke
let me try another
mp40 or the thompson are pretty good
the default classes hmm
okay i'll try this uh default thompson
class they have
go back to a i'm tired of getting killed
at b
oh this one's got the tracker footsteps
cool
someone else is here nope
thanks for being here guys appreciate
you guys uh all stopping him by to say
what's up and check out the game
um i'll read chat in just a second
there you go hide behind this wall see
what's up
pc is good at fps games only come on man
consoles got good fps games
[Music]
someone's over here i can feel it i saw
someone die over here
dang it
the sound of the game question mark
question mark
do weapons feel good yeah
i mean that's all opinion native but uh
if you like modern warfare it feels like
that
so i i'm enjoying
the uh the gun play as it were
definitely
all right
charlie where's that mp40 what is this
yeah i'll take this
this is a good uh this is a good gun for
so far lower the game volume
so we said everything game volume sounds
low yeah it is
it is
um i thought they would fix that after
we played like that private beta but
i can also turn it up um
last time on the stream my voice was too
low so i wanted to just balance that out
but
uh if you guys want me to crank up the
game volume a little like
press one in the chat if not press two
game volume up press one let me know
even by a little just just let me know
i want this to be enjoyable for you guys
so you can hear the sounds of this game
as well
oh my god the recoil i'm ass
although that was long range
yeah i'm not using this uh smg not i'm
not using the thompson on this map
anymore
all right all right i'll play the
objective i usually do i'm just
caught up y'all i'm caught up
someone died right in front of me
whoa
we have the same thought dang it
okay
turning up the game volume
a smidge thank you guys by the way
okay i've cranked it up
um
let me know if it's too
losing
loud
baker rounds almost over say goodnight
charlie is ours going for a going for a
baker is overrun
no i don't want them to win we're so
close
throwing the smoke grenade
no
come on come on
three is not an option five is not an
option come on y'all
but let me know if that sounds okay
there we go let's get a good example me
talking them shooting how's the sound
that dude went on a rampage
one by one point yeah good lord
woohoo
all right let me see what i can unlock
i'm gonna check the guns look at i
unlock some stuff
but i want to see what uh what else i
unlocked
gg thank you
i mean not on my behalf but we
we snuck we snuck that wind
i hate this little
there we go clear all there we go the
little dots annoy me so much i always
try to clear them out
let's see loadouts let me um
stg i still i still haven't
i still been unlocked stuff for this
okay got the scope terrific
so many scopes
i guess i have to stick with one gun you
know if i want to quickly level it up
for the stream but
i want to play around with all the guns
so
oh well not much has changed i'm just
going to keep
yeah i haven't even unlocked more kill
streaks at this point
unlocked at level 10 25 level nine okay
yeah no i'm a mere level five
whoa
let's get back into it
yes it is only for playstation right now
if you only and only if you pre-ordered
the game which is silly but
i have the dates here
uh if you if you're on playstation
you can play this weekend if you
pre-order the game
on september 16th through the 17th
xbox and battlenet pc players get their
early access if they pre-ordered
um on september 16th through the 20th
it's also an open beta for playstation
users
and then september 18th through the 20th
xbox and battlenet pc players
get their open beta
and it'll be cross play too
san yeah the weapon customization is
is pretty much like modern warfare
they're adding they're adding a lot of
stuff you can have 10 attachments on
an smg if you wanted it's pretty nuts
let me try the default class there are
some good default classes
or at least stuff i can't unlock that i
don't have unlocked yet
the bar i'm not good with let me try the
mg42
the burst rifle
um i'll give it a shot
sci-fi no you can't play this you cannot
play this weekend if you didn't
pre-order that's that's what they're
saying that's what the early access part
is
he's right here come on
where'd he go i want to test out this
rifle and get a kill
oh i don't think that oh there he is
i was killed he was killed for me
this map is is cool but like it's uh i
think i mentioned it before it's easy to
get pinned down in your spawn area
what's up
slow reaction time on that one
let me get a long range kill i'm gonna
i'm gonna hang back and see if i can get
a cool kill with this three round burst
gun
uh because i don't think i'll be using
it the whole match i'm not good with uh
three round bursts
someone over here
shoot
yeah i don't have the guts
see here hello this is all destructible
by the way i think you can shoot yeah
you can shoot through this stuff
which is pretty cool although when i
every time i hung out over there i got
sniped from the other side
so that's not cool
there they
are got one
was that four shots
oh
this sounded like four that's pretty
cool normally it's always three round
bursts
peak oh oh good thing i didn't open the
door move stupid door ah
that door was trying to tell me hey man
back up you're about to get killed
which is why we just need to pick the
pick 10 system that's a classic
call of duty way to do things
oh yeah i don't want to use this gun
anymore um not getting the hottest
gameplay
oh
get me out of here there's a rock or
something there we go someone's up here
for sure
negative
yeah i'm in the middle of the map i need
a faster gun what's my backup
the panzer shrek okay here we go
okay now i feel a little more secure
let's check it out this is where b is
and domination like the center of the
map it's nuts when you're playing blitz
mode
blitz mode is that 24v24 that's not a
door
and i want to play it for stream but
right now it's only they only have a
tactical mode unlocked which is 6v6
finally got a kill i felt like it's been
forever man
someone's over here though i saw them
run away
interested to know if you guys in chat
did you guys play world war ii from 2017
um
because i'm you know the guns here are
the same ones from that game
and i want to know if you like that game
because
i mean you might be at home here
what class is this
i picked the wrong class again i'm just
goofing up here y'all
i'll take this back though woohoo
oh friendly oh no
ando
stephen says yeah i loved
world war ii all right
fine
blue and red bars on the bottom was the
score
the final kill man i really wish
blitz mode was unlocked that was i'm to
keep i'm going to keep saying that um
blitz mode was so fun it was crazy oh
look at that well at least it's a 1kd
but
i jumped into that match late
and also i stink
let's see here
i wonder at which point
leave lobby
see on the top left there where it says
quick play and filtered
i wonder when that unlocks because if
you unlock that then you can change
combat pacing which is what i want to do
outdated computer well appreciate you
being here anyway man gamespot is a
pretty big deal uh so i don't know how
you found us we make a lot of video game
videos and like just in general so could
have been anything
um
but hey thanks for being here hope you
like call of duty
if he says i just got my pc back i'm so
happy nice
ah see uh it's back to tactical 6v6 i
want i want more
how do i change that i still can't i
swear i can't right now
probably until like level 10 or
something
red star okay this is the big snowy city
map
okay
thompson
the shotgun is not good for this map
the bar maybe i'll try the bar again
i'll give it another shot
oh but it's uh kill confirmed okay
i won gotta go get those tags though oh
some guy died right next to me i should
have picked those up first
yikes that was such a slow slide
hello anyone here i'm gonna go pick up
those tags while i can that's how you
win this game boys
oh no behind me
going for it anyway
the the bar is okay i mean it's working
out for me in in this match in this
scenario
sort of
man
use a sniper man you don't want to see
that kind of gameplay
yeah ken ken bottom line
to each of their own i guess that's just
for call of duty players in general to
each their own
whoa
you'll live
whoa did you guys see that gun on the
ground what was he using
nope not that one
oh it's a thompson with a bunch of
funny grips and stocks and stuff on it
come on guys pick up your tags that's
how we win
got it got it
hey
there we go
i feel like the hulk or juggernaut
juggernog remember that
i said that by mistake
boom
oh someone has the goliath that little
robot thing
no what am i doing just standing here
manu menu yeah
i hear you i hear you whoa
i think blew up
let's get these tags friends come on
okay
another goliath
yoink
oh yeah i haven't been on the roof yet
this is where the snipers like to go
there's a goliath it's like that little
rc car
you can't it doesn't shoot things but
you can run people over and then it
blows up and then you blow up
wow that was excellent timing
right in the head man
oh no
hmm
i had the captions on last time i played
and the kill feed
or the caption like feeds
is nuts the whole like the whole bottom
of the screen was just dedicated to all
these words and people yelling out
things it was
nuts i feel like more than before though
like
i normally put on the captions
this year just felt like a lot there was
a lot of stuff on screen so that must
mean they're really chatty these
characters
okay i saw someone on my left i saw them
running across here
whoa yikes
how's the sniping ads um
you know what i'll just snipe there are
enough people have been asking uh i
always say that i'm not the best sniper
so i just want to put that out there but
um let's find out
come on
oh that's the bird here we go the
three-line rifle
there you go that's
pretty it's okay that's what i would
call normal but
everyone's always looking for a super
fast ads and i don't blame them this is
just kind of a run-of-the-mill
scope
i think it's the default scope
um yeah
yeah look at that see you don't want to
see me sniping guys i'm
not freaking out
throw the c4 whatever the hell this
doesn't get the hell out of here
i need yeah i can only
i only ever snipe when i like need to or
like in zombies or something i never
for for obvious reasons
but i know that about myself
i do want to get better though
because it can be
it can be crazy when you're an excellent
sharpshooter like game over you know
although some people see that as like
this game is not balanced when that
happens
how's quick scoping yeah no way dude i
can't i'm afraid i can't do that for you
today
unless there's like a zombie in front of
me and no way am i going to quick scope
whoa
random explosion
there's someone over there and i just
missed them
hmm
you can fix like in modern warfare and
war zone or whatever or even cold war
you can fix
your aim down sights sensitivity like
when i go left and right so i think i
should do that by a little bit
i swear i swear it won't help me but not
much
multiplier
is that the one
show more here we go look at that oh my
god that's extensive
show less why can't i get to this menu
oh there we go okay
yeah look that's very specific um i will
deal with that later but it's good to
know that it's there
take this stg
nice pick up your tags friend you earned
that kill
did i tell you guys
but they uh
they sent me dog tags and like
call of duty sent me a cool jacket that
says like vanguard and some dog tags and
a hat and this
water jug thing
um
that was cool like the first time i ever
got something from
you know
uh uh sorry i got distracted it's like
the first time i ever got any cool like
merch from them
this little pistol is not bad but i
don't i gotta change my class i'm so
scatterbrained at the moment
okay let's see here
mp40 solid i'm just going to go with
that
carlos says i know this is just beta
this is just a beta but this game looks
like
ass
all right man
that's cool you are you're here you're
here to make that opinion that's why you
stopped by today
uh but carlos let me know what call of
duty in your opinion doesn't look like
ass what's your favorite call of duty
he was okay you can walk up here nice
uh carlos sorry if i miss your comment
i'm
but i'm interested to see
what you
think okay i should have lost that fight
got the intel let me check it out here
why is the reticle floating yeah it's uh
i don't know i think it's just an effect
watch this
i mean it's a regular effect isn't it
i've seen that before
like that you mean
someone just walked in here oh
these maps look kind of big uh sci-fi
these some of them are um
there weren't any small maps it was like
medium and large uh from from the beta i
think there's four maps
yeah the hotel
the beach
this one
oh an eagle's nest which i think comes
out later later this weekend eagles nest
is like probably the smallest map and
it's like
this indoor mountaintop map
um i liked it i wish we were playing it
today oh
out outgunned outplayed out everything
when does the console beta come out
josiah my friend you are looking at it
if you pre-ordered
call of duty vanguard you're able to
play on playstation this weekend if you
didn't pre-order you can play next
weekend
on playstation it's open
we won
andrew i'm streaming i think until like
um
for another 15 minutes 11 11 30ish
pacific time
oh if you're trying to redeem your code
it'll probably it'll probably
it'll probably be for the open beta for
next weekend
i'll read the dates here while we wait
um
this weekend is early access obviously
for playstation people who pre-ordered
september 16th through the 17th
xbox and battlenet pc players get their
early access if they pre-ordered
but also on september 16 16 through the
20th
it's the open beta for all playstation
players you don't have to pre-order
september 18th through the 20th
uh open beta for all
and i think it's supposed to be cross
cross play too
hope that helps
this should also yes be on playstation
4. i heard some people had some problems
downloading it this morning but it
should be
available
can i try to make a fast ads sniper i
can try i'll make one i'll try to make
one next match but you guys see my
sniper play i'm not
i'm not big on sniping so i'll make one
i'll i'll show you what it's like but i
will probably won't be using it for much
of the match because i stink
i like this gun uh the vault
take your time and remember to think
see here i can go around right yeah
going up
boy i guess i just missed everyone
okay that's not a door just wanted to go
back outside
rats i got killed by god himself
yeah the volk is back and despite that
terrible death you just watched it's a
good gun um can you inspect in this game
let me see here oh single fire
no you can't inspect though
no all right i'm done trying
i feel like they change it every game
and they shouldn't change it
it should always be one thing
universally
oh no look who i
killed oh man it went away but it said
the little nos x
please no br i'm tired of br there's no
br in the um
the beta bill that's for sure
there you go where you going around we
what the hell
okay here's the destructible glass
well i was trying to show you the
destructible glass let me move my mic
there we go
how's that sound i usually i tend to
move away from the mic and it sucks when
i do that
uh
because i already speak at a low volume
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
okay i deserve to die there i was trying
to that was a mess that person could
have killed me like twice
uh you're on xbox
and the pre-ordered isn't working yeah
xbox you can't play this weekend if you
pre-order it on xbox that is the date
for that is i think the 18th
you know what you did
you know what you did
yo what the
oh they're below me okay i'm just trying
to
one of them is holy crap
there we go
it's funny to see you can just name
yourself anything like little moss x
million bucks says that's not him
obviously it's not but it's just funny
to be called that someone else was named
god in this lobby
oh no
shoot
oh he's above me
smoke out
stupid idea
tar heel says this [ __ ] is cheeks
show
okay
target i'm not gonna i'm not gonna put
that one up but
tar heel does not look like the look of
this game
also
uh this isn't like you know
high level gameplay this is just
that's a friendly one
no
sorry i don't want to yell into the mine
this mic i think has a good
uh like
uh i forget what it's called like a
sound gate if i yell too loud it should
block peaking
i find myself here in this part of the
map a lot i'm gonna get out of here i
don't this is
where's the action i'm gonna go into the
center
get myself killed here
there we go
that was a loud ass reload
hmm oh a wine cellar
someone's right here watch
no behind us
get zooks
use my intel
do you guys i mean
when you play call of duty do you do
like that like
attack jumping jump shots i don't
never got into that and like now
i feel like i can always start if i
wanted to because i see how well it
works
i just always hated it
uh drop shotting is one thing i that's a
that's a real
classic um
uh uh
technique in my my opinion but jump
shotting i feel like i annoyed me
because i
you know it's not you do that in halo i
don't know i feel like jumping shouldn't
be here
and call of duty vaulting is one thing
but jumping i don't know
it works and maybe it works too well and
i'm just an old man but
you know let me know if you guys do god
i can't sorry i tried looking at the
chat but let me know what you guys feel
about jump shotting i still can't get
into it
uh gigi in the chat says do you like
this game honest opinion um i do so far
i do this beta also is really cool
compared to the
the alpha which only had champion hill
mode
um
because you know i'm getting i'm getting
the full multiplayer experience this
time around 6v6 you know
i want to play um
i want to play
24v24 but it wasn't working i don't know
maybe it's later in the weekend
yeah dukes
we won but no thanks to me
bunny hop yeah bunny hopping you guys
you guys do you guys as the viewers do
you do that do you jump around and kill
your enemy that way
i hate it but i i understand how well it
works
and i don't do it
crazy gaming lol says another stupid
world war style game
well
crazy gaming if you like modern warfare
this might this might might be worth a
shot the open beta for you you should
try because well i don't know i don't
know what
fps games you like but
it's true there's no denying it this is
another world war ii game but it's like
um it's got a lot of influences from the
last few games
sushi sand says i absolutely hate bunny
hopping
tar heel says cod should just drop
another cod every two years yeah
the yearly cycle
sounds so stressful for everyone
involved so
i agree
i think they should take a little break
you know it's not like an iphone that's
even worse that's a terrible analogy
iphones have come out almost every year
too and so many people work on those
like let's take a break you know like uh
maybe do one every other year
oh the suppression system no i haven't
um i can't customize that my gun
that far yet
um
but i think it has it doesn't have much
more to do with your suppression barrel
as much as it does subsonic rounds
that's how you stay off the map there
are subsonic ammo rounds
which you need to unlock
and then um
then you stay off the map like for real
for real
okay this will probably be my last round
you guys it is
quickly approaching 11 30.
so i'm gonna try to sweat it out use the
stg which i love get you some good
gameplay here
what are we playing though what um
patrol
patrol is like a hardpoint game mode
where the hardpoint moves so
it's not my favorite but
i will try to be a team player
ah crap
already surrounded
it depends i hope i'm saying that right
it depends when what console you have
because pre-order dates i'm sorry uh
open beta dates are different for every
console including pc but i'll give you
the dates at the end of this match uh i
can't look at my little paper right now
there we go
see the patrol point is moving ah man
zero h says imagine spending 10 years of
your life making call of duty games
some people have been in the studio for
that long i'm sure
ah but got him
okay cosmic cat
bobby says you seem to like this do you
plan on getting battlefield 2042 yeah um
i do like it i
i am enjoying my time with the beta and
i am really excited for battlefield
because i never played one before um
i always just stuck with like
call of duty
and
this here will be my first battlefield
so i'm excited for that too
uh
where was he throwing right back at you
homie
take this as my backup
well
oh god scared me oh crap
goodness
oh my leg blew up my leg
you don't know which studio is making
this one this one is made by
sledgehammer games
sledgehammer games made world war ii
from 2017
and advanced warfare
and they helped out with modern warfare
3.
you know what you did
oh come on i thought i had that guy
yeah they do alternate studios
someone is just going off firing
everything here we go
oh there was a red barrel there cool i
hope it blows up
there were a few red barrels there
all right guess he left
oh no above me
shooting through this uh cover here oh
no
dang it
jeremy
got killed by jeremy
we see let me go around here let me get
tactical
there we go we got it back friends
oh no
wow that guy got me through like the
thickest of grass
will there ever be a cod advanced
warfare 2
things ended pretty
at least for the story things ended
nicely there i don't think there needs
to be a part two but you never know
ah
let me try something faster
where's that mp40 class i like that
class oh no the vault was dope i'll do
that
okay at least we're on the hardpoint we
got 99 points 100 points
nice use a glide bomb right on it now we
have it
should have thrown it back tank
yes it will be uh
uh call of duty vanguard
will be
uh
put in they're gonna sorry i couldn't do
both apparently uh there's going to be a
new vanguard warzone map
they call it like the next chapter of
warzone
they barely showed anything though i
think they showed some like still frames
but it's happening probably you know
later next few years
no i had to reload but i could have got
a triple
could have shoulda would have what the
that was a terrible spawn
for him
not for me
[Music]
oh friendly friendly friendly
let's catch back up i thought we were
waiting but we aren't
dang it
let me back up here and kill the dudes
who are
killing my dudes
oh i thought i had him
oh you hate what they did to you for
modern warfare 2019 what do you mean how
they added everything cold war into a
war zone
where was he oh well that dude keeps
getting me
oh no right here watch
that was terrible i'll give myself an f
ah okay i could have redeemed myself but
no
come on i gotta play the objective a
little harder
i i'm not in the patrol zone
there we go
there we go no i'm not in
what the
there we go oh no
he was chilling goon right here dang it
i wish the game had no reload like doom
that'd be cool
it'd be a very broken mode but yeah sure
oh no
wow where the hell am i going here we go
thanks for that we have the lead keep it
up
we have the advantage come on
richie the dragon all right from from oh
crap
from one richie to another i respect you
dang it
where is it
no they're gonna catch up look at the
score damn
ah
damn i could i could have turned that
around for us
come on guys let's go to the patrol zone
never mind too busy getting
killed which studio made this one tyler
this was a sledgehammer games they made
they're making this one this year
come on i had shots on that guy
oh my god come on get in there yeah
no they're gonna take it look at the
score
the oh no what oh
damn look at this is like
ah it's over it's rats
my team started to play the objective
at the end yeah
me too for the most part but damn that
was close
uh raven tyler to answer your question
ravert ravensof raven studios or raven
software excuse me
uh they they're more of a support studio
nowadays for a war zone but
they also were a support studio for
infinity ward i think and modern warfare
3 and
one of the other games maybe two other
games but
we're gonna wrap it up here guys i just
wanted to let me turn this down and read
you some important dates
so if you guys are uh this mic is right
in my face that's funny
there we go now that i'm not looking at
that screen
great
um so for everyone asking hey hello
hello welcome ah we're about to end it
we're about to wrap it up here
but um
this weekend if you pre-ordered
the uh if you pre-ordered a call of duty
vanguard you're able to play on
playstation
um from this from the 10th through the
13th
and the rest of the dates here we go
september 16th through the 17th
you're able to play on xbox and battle
net you know on pc if if you pre-ordered
um
take these off
ouch okay and on september 16th through
the 20th you're able to play on
playstation open beta you don't even
have to have pre-ordered
that's on the 16th through the 20th
and then on september 18th through the
20th uh it's open beta
xbox battle net playstation open beta
so i hope that helps you guys i hope you
guys had fun today
watching me try to sweat it out but uh
that's gonna do it for our stream today
let me swap over here
boom all right thank you guys so much
for watching happy friday have a good
weekend and enjoy the beta if you're
gonna be playing i'll see you guys